so stellen wir uns landwirtschaft gerne
vor grüne wiesen glückliche tiere leben
auf dem bauernhof dass die realität oft
anders aussieht das wissen wir auch und
sie wissen es noch besser
die bauern und die sind widmet man hat
einfach wirklich angst um die zukunft
und und getrieben von dieser angst und
aus diesen leuten heraus ist diese
bewegung entstanden in dieser folge
summen geht es darum warum das
allerhöchste zeit ist dass die
landwirtin und bauern protestieren
denn viele fehler liegen im system die
politik hat in den vergangenen jahren
grandios versagt seit herbst gehen
tausende bäuerinnen und landwirt er auf
die straßen um gegen neue auflagen gegen
mehr natur- und tierschutz zu
protestieren anderen gehen die reform
wiederum nicht weit genug
umweltschützer aber auch diese bauern
und natur verbände fordern noch mehr
nachhaltigkeit sie wollen weg von der
industriellen landwirtschaft dass so
viele demonstrieren zeigt dass es auf
den höfen wirklich schlimm ist dass sich
etwas bewegen muss dass wir einen wandel
brauchen
[Musik]
schauen wir uns zuerst mal die akuten
probleme an und dann darauf wie wir
überhaupt da hingekommen sind die lobby
und politik lange reformen verschleppt
und aufgestaut haben das so genannte
agrar paket der bundesregierung hat im
herbst 2009 10 das fass zum überlaufen
gebracht mit diesen säulen sollte die
landwirtschaft auf einen schlag
nachhaltiger werden
mit änderungen bei den direktzahlungen
mit dem aktionsprogramm insektenschutz
mit dem freiwilligen tierwohl label der
veränderung der dünne ordnung und dem
klimapaket also strengere tierschutz um
umweltschutz auflagen weniger gülle fürs
grundwasser mir blühstreifen für
insekten und so weiter
das war der auslöser für die grünen
kreuz am straßenrand und die großen
traktor proteste es ging den bäuerinnen
und bauern zu weit zu teuer zu viel
zusätzliche bürokratie ist es eine große
herausforderung ohne zusätzliche
unterstützung und natürlich schädigt
kein landwirt gerne die umwelt sie sind
ja von der natur abhängig die gründe
dafür liegen tiefer von der romantischen
vorstellung des kleinen dorf bahnhofs
ist nicht mehr viel übrig die
konventionelle landwirtschaft wurde
immer weiter ausgebaut und
industrialisiert hühner legen heute zum
beispiel mehr als doppelt so viele wie
noch mal 150 kühe geben dreimal so viel
milch und auf denselben feldern wächst
dreimal so viel weizen
jahrzehntelang wurde optimiert und
ausgebaut und jetzt sind so langsam die
grenzen erreicht
denn der preis dafür am weltmarkt
mithalten zu können es hoch die
intensive landwirtschaft braucht gifte
dünger und medikamente verkürzt gesagt
ist das schlecht für die böden fürs
grundwasser für die nutztiere völlig
insekten fürs klima aber höhere
standards kosten auf mehr geld und schon
kleine veränderungen können sich manche
bauern kaum leisten
neben dem weltmarkt bestimmt in
deutschland die vier großen
supermarktketten aldi lidl rewe und
edeka die preise und lebensmittel sind
in deutschland extrem billig die politik
wird in regelmäßigen abständen gegen die
dumpingpreise vorgehen aber nicht
festlegen
im extremfall zahlen die milch schweine
und obstbauern also drauf selbst für die
kleinen preise brauchen sie masse
die eu gipfel nicht so viel geld aus wie
für agrarsubventionen alle eu
bürgerinnen und bürger zahlen grob 30
cent steuern pro tag für die förderung
der landwirtschaft so kommen rund 60
milliarden euro zusammen und die werden
auf zwei säulen verteilt bei der
größeren säule gilt je mehr fläche man
hat desto mehr geld bekommt man egal wie
nachhaltig darauf und wirtschaftet wird
es gibt also keine anreize für klima-
oder umweltschutz und je größer der
betrieb desto mehr geld auch so
verschwinden immer mehr kleine betriebe
es ist ein fehler im system
und gerade wird auf eu ebene jetzt
wieder darüber verhandelt aber die
bundesregierung will am alten system
festhalten
eines der argumente die eu bauern sollen
weltweit konkurrenzfähig bleiben
zusätzlich steigt der kostendruck auch
auf einer ganz anderen ebene die preise
für agrarland und verpachten steigen und
das auch deshalb weil seit der
finanzkrise immer mehr investoren
einsteigen und land kaufen
zu den ganzen harten faktoren die
preiskampf subventionen politik und so
weiter kommt ein ganz weiter dazu die
geringe akzeptanz und wertschätzung
in den meisten umfragen kommt immer
wieder raus dass die meisten menschen
landwirtschaft für sehr wichtig halten
und unterstützen wollen am besten in
kleinbäuerlichen betrieben aber in
umfragen kauft auch jeder bio und in der
realität sind grob 5 prozent das fühlt
sich nicht so richtig nach wertschätzung
an viele landwirt hin fühlen sich wie
die deppen der nation
und seien wir mal ehrlich sie haben
wieder medial noch gesellschaftlich den
besten stand also seit jahren sind jetzt
zum beispiel die düngeverordnung so dass
die eu sogar mit einer klage brot und
der tierschutz mit in deutschland nicht
eingehalten und dass wir teilweise auch
vom staat geduldet
der druck kommt jetzt von allen seiten
von der eu vom handel von klimaschützern
von tierschützern und von der
gesellschaft die
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin klöckner
sagt selbst er sei noch nie so hoch
gewesen
aber woran liegt das
das subventionssystem stützt ein
kaputtes system und die politik hat es
verschlafen zu handeln
notwendige und wichtige reformen wurden
in der agrarpolitik seit jahren
verschleppt nicht wenige experten und
wissenschaftler schreiben das dem
einfluss der agrarlobby zu eine studie
der uni krems zeigt auf dass viele
entscheidungsträger im größten verband
dem deutschen bauernverband diverse
posten einnehmen und kritiker werfen
jetzt dem verband vor dass er nicht die
bauern schützt sondern seine eigenen
geschäfte
das bundesumweltministerium schreibt
sich selbst eine mitschuld an der
situation zu die schlechte umweltbilanz
der landwirtschaft ist deshalb vor allem
auch die konsequenz einer verfehlten
landwirtschaftspolitik und ihrer
förderinstrumente denn die bauern haben
so investiert und gewirtschaftet wie es
die gegebenheiten und die gesetze eben
fordern beispielsweise eben mit
glyphosat dessen stopp der letzte
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister der csu im
alleingang an doch noch verhindert hat
und jetzt ist der gesellschaftliche und
politische druck so groß dass was
passieren muss und damit rollt auf die
bauern eine reform welle zu gegen diese
sich stimmen und was machen wir jetzt
eine sache ist ganz einfach hat respekt
vor dem job den die bauern und landwirte
machen
trotzdem muss natürlich klar sein es
kann nicht so bleiben wie es ist und
einige der protestbewegung fordern aber
genau das und das wäre ein fehler denn
es braucht strengere standards und
eigentlich einen radikalen
politikwechsel im agrarsektor
umweltschonende landwirtschaft und
tiergerechte haltung müssten sich auch
ökonomisch lohnen und dafür muss
zuallererst die politik sorgen also
dieser betrieb macht ja ganz ganz viel
für den naturschutz und müsste aus
meiner sicht eben dafür auch bezahlt
werden aber aufgrund dieser ganzen
regularien nur das nicht natürlich kann
auch jede und jeder von uns was dafür
tun denn wer billig kauft der
unterstützt das system man kann nämlich
nicht gegen pestizide sein und mehr
tirol fordern und was dann nicht
bezahlen auch wenn es jetzt natürlich
nicht nur in der hand von uns
verbraucherinnen liegt haben wir doch
einen ziemlich großen anteil daran und
deswegen würde mich interessieren ob ihr
darauf achtet regional
zu kaufen oder geht ihr auf
wochenmärkten direkt zum bauern schreibt
mir das doch mal in die kommentare weil
es mich wirklich interessieren würde
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch für landwirtschaft
interessiert könnt ihr hier jemanden
kennenlernen der für kleinbäuerlichen
landwirtschaft kämpft und hier gibt es
noch viele andere spannende themen von
summen